all right and we have Lord kognito of
the iron Lord podcast the inner circle
games network or Cargill you just played
the division 2 what do you think I'm
impressed I'm impressed I mean I'll be
honest I'm not the biggest division guy
actually I'm a destiny guy that's our
in-law podcast but at the end of the day
look I mean it felt great I feel it's a
little more of the same I felt for K 30
it's looking like I'm a lot of new
gameplay mechanics there was a new mode
that kind of like you can call for help
you shoot like a flare up in the air
kind of thing but initial feel in the
game for those who love division I think
they're gonna continue to love division
you know and see what's going on for
guys like me I kind of need to see what
other nuances they have to draw me in as
well as endgame people who enjoyed the
original division you say they're likely
to enjoy the gameplay present here what
do you think the greatest challenge will
be for the division 2 after the
challenges that the first game face I
think it's just like I said I think
ultimately comes down to the end game
that the core gameplay loop is there as
far as like getting the mid maxing we're
doing your builds that whole kind of
thing those people who love that minutia
are going to love this game and that's
back in full force graphically detail
the game looks phenomenal I will say
this to cut the details are the
character models the grass the world it
looked great anything like that but
again for those are the fence from what
I've seen we just I need to see a little
bit more or something else unique
that'll be like ok boom
now you mentioned 4k 30 you mentioned
really good-looking graphics in it would
you like to see a mode where the
graphics are perhaps downgrade the
resolution goes down a bit to make it
hit that for a second good question I
think so I think um if this was like at
1080 60 and a shot oh boy John John
Lennon when he saw the PC build and he
said that was running at 60 but at
certain points it was kind of struggling
to maintain that on PC so I'm assuming
for the actions probably gonna be 4k 30
you know again this is all speculation I
have no confirmation on that just yet
we'll get more information later post
and be it
you know the whole thing is I think that
yeah it would be cool if they offered
like a 1086 Teemo if it was possible
all right
[Music]